[Applaudissements]
chers amis quelle aventure incroyable
quelle aventure incroyable d'être ici
devant vous ce matin devant vous tous et
je voudrais commencer en vous disant
tout simplement du fond du coeur un
immense merci un immense un profond un
sincère merci pour la confiance que vous
me faites et ce merci il va d'abord à
notre président à celui qui a fait ce
choix fou je veux remercier laurent
wauquiez je n'aurais pas pensé je vous
le dis sincèrement je n'aurais pas pensé
il y a quelques mois il y a quelques
semaines encore me trouver ici ce matin
pour conduire cette liste à l'élection
européenne et je voudrais vous dire une
chose très simple je sais au fond de moi
même que je ne mérite pas cette mission
et que je vais devoir maintenant tout
faire pour la mériter je ne peux pas
vous dire tout ce que j'ai fait je ne
peux pas vous dire tout ce que j'ai
gagné tout le travail que j'ai accompli
qui me vaudrait d'être ici je sais que
l'essentiel est devant et qu'il me
faudra mériter votre confiance tout au
long de cette campagne et dans les
années qui viennent
en étant à la hauteur du choix que vous
avez fait
d'autres que moi aurait été infiniment
plus légitime pour porter cette aventure
européenne et d'autres que moi ont tracé
le sillon dans lequel je vais maintenant
m'engager je pense à nos parlementaires
européens sortants qui font ce choix
courageux de s'engager derrière une
jeune tête de liste et qui m'ont dès le
début témoignez d'une bienveillance qui
me touche profondément
merci cher franck poste en particulier
je pense à toutes ces grandes figures de
notre mouvement qui ont marqué l'action
qui a été porté au cours des dernières
années et qui là aussi depuis le début
de cette aventure me parle me
conseillent me guide dans une vie
politique mes chers amis qui est si
souvent rongé par une forme
d'individualisme dévastateur nous
pouvons avoir la certitude d'avoir une
belle famille politique dans laquelle la
solidarité n'est pas un vain mot
je l ai vécue concrètement depuis ces
dernières semaines et je voulais vous
dire aujourd'hui à quelle point je suis
reconnaissant de toute cette confiance
qui s'est exprimé et qui me donne la
force aujourd'hui de porter le projet
qui nous attend pour les semaines qui
s'engage
merci chers annie genevard merci cher
jean leonetti merci bien sûr à tous ceux
qui m'accompagnent aussi dans cette
aventure je voudrais remercier daniel
fasquelle qui a accepté courageusement
de prendre en charge la dimension
financière de cette campagne et ça
compte bien sûr pour que nous puissions
avec ambition défendre vos idées
merci à françois noël buffet qui
l'accompagnent également et je voudrais
vous dire aussi combien je sais que dans
cette aventure ce qui sera décisif pour
nous c'est la complémentarité c'est le
lien c'est l'unité profonde qui se crée
entre nous on en fait beaucoup sur la
tête de liste je suis bien placé pour le
savoir et vous êtes nombreux à me dire
ce matin ça marche bien bravo bravo et
j'en suis vraiment très touché
mais je vais vous dire une chose toute
simple si ça marche si bien c'est parce
que ça a commencé dès le début et que ce
sera jusqu'à la fin une aventure
d'equipe c'est une aventure des clips
et cher laurent sous ta responsabilité
sous ta conduite en relation permanente
avec toi avec la belle équipe qui
conduit notre mouvement
j'ai eu la joie d'être investi dès le
début avec agnès et arnaud et c'est une
grande chance pour moi une chance
immense que d'avoir créé avec eux dès le
début de cette campagne des liens
profonds qui sont des liens d'amitié
sincère et je veux les en remercier
depuis le début de cette campagne nous
portons ce projet ensemble et je
voudrais vous dire à quel point lorsque
je parlais que vous m'entendez vous
entendez en fait ce qu'ils montrent a
pris ce qu'ils m'ont transmis ce que
j'ai partagé avec eux share and f qui
est vice-présidente de la première
région d'europe avec valérie pécresse
cher arnaud toi qui es parlementaires
européens sortants et vous avez entendu
à quel point sa compétence fait autorité
depuis le début de cette campagne c'est
vous qui me partager le regard que vous
pensez nécessaire pour notre europe et
depuis le début de cette campagne alors
que nous incarnons peut-être des
histoires un peu différente
il n'y a pas entre nous la plus petite
divergence sur l'europe que nous voulons
sur l'europe que nous voulons défendre
avec vous et défendre pour vous
vous avez mois pour ce qui me concerne
je n'ai jamais cru à l'opposition de
l'ancien et du nouveau monde et je n'ai
jamais pensé quatre nouveaux étaient
forcément meilleurs qu'être anciens et
j'ai même toujours pensé au contraire
que quand on était jeunes ce n'était pas
une qualité mais c'était une exigence
supplémentaire
je le vis comme élu local depuis dix ans
comme tant d'entre vous sur le terrain
ce qui fait la force de nos équipes
municipales partout en france c'est la
complémentarité entre l'expérience et le
renouvellement entre l'imagination et la
connaissance entre la compétence et la
créativité et c'est ça que nous allons
incarner ce sera une aventure d' équipe
et je ne serai que le porte-voix d'une
équipe magnifique qui s'est déjà
constitué avec tous les parlementaires
européens sortants avec des élus de
toute la france vous les avez vus ici
ils sont notre fierté ils sont notre
chance
ils seront notre réussite collective et
j'en serai seulement le serviteur pour
être hôte à la tête de cette liste le
porte-voix de cette pluralité de cette
complémentarité qui nous rendra efficace
pour vous représenter demain et pour
défendre les intérêts de la france en
europe et de l'europe dans le monde
cette campagne je l'abordé donc avec une
très profonde
une immense humilité et j'ai laborde
aussi avec le sentiment tout aussi
profond tout aussi grave de ma
responsabilité car nous sommes dans un
moment décisif de notre histoire de
l'histoire de notre pays de l'histoire
de l'europe de l'histoire de notre
famille politique aussi et les trois
sont étroitement liés un moment
singulier de l'histoire de notre pays
qui traverse une crise profonde
je fais partie d'une génération chez
alexandre tu l'as dit nous sommes sans
doute lié par cette expérience qui a vu
sa conscience du monde l'être à travers
le mot de crise
partout où notre regard se porte nous
voyons de la crise crise économique
crise sociale crise de l'intégration
crise de la culture crise de la
transmission crise éducative même la
nature est en crise rien ne semble fixer
stable tout semble aujourd'hui incertain
tout semble aujourd'hui menacée de ce à
quoi nous tenons et dans cette crise au
fond il n'y a pas de fatalité ce n'est
même pas une catastrophe la crise vous
savez en grec dans cette langue qui a
fait l'europe
le mot crise veut dire décision la crise
c'est le moment de faire un choix
c'est le moment de faire les bons choix
et nous avons à proposer aux français
avec persévérance avec constance avec
sérieux le choix nécessaires pour
pouvoir fonder notre avenir et c'est le
sens de ce rendez vous européen qui
s'annonce
notre monde entier connaît cette crise
que j'évoquais à l'instant tous les
jeunes du monde aujourd'hui peuvent
regarder l'avenir avec un peu
d'inquiétude
je suis heureux d'être d'ailleurs dans
cette aventure entouré de quelques
belles figures de jeunes qui m'entourent
ici et aussi bien sûr sur notre liste
sheikh livia cher faustine de visages de
la jeunesse et d'une jeunesse qui veut
s'engager pour pouvoir faire ses choix
courageux que notre civilisation à temps
pour pouvoir continuer d'exister face à
la crise migratoire qui est devant nous
et non pas derrière nous
nous avons besoin de faire des choix
courageux en europe face à la crise
économique
nous avons besoin de sortir de cette
naïveté coupable naïveté de la france en
europe
naïveté de l'europe dans le monde nous
avons besoin de défendre de nouveau nos
entreprises nos emplois de défendre nos
agriculteurs et depuis le début de cette
campagne
j'entends
j'entends tellement d'entre eux me dire
qu'ils ne croient plus à l'europe
emmanuel macron nous dit que le grand
danger pour l'europe c'est la montée de
la défiance
emmanuel macron nous dit que le grand
danger pour l'euro c'est le populisme et
de nationalisme mais moi je dis que le
grand danger pour l'europe c'est que
dans l'europe de la politique agricole
commune qui l'a laissé se défaire et se
détricoter dans l'europe de la politique
agricole commune malgré nos politiques
un agriculteur se donne la mort tous les
deux jours ça c'est le grand danger pour
l'europe
et quand des agriculteurs me dise moi
l'europe je n'y crois plus je ne me sens
pas en droit de les insulter en les
traitant de populiste
je dois seulement nous devons seulement
les écouter et répondre à leurs
inquiétudes
et c'est ainsi que nous feront monter
cette défiance qui monte partout envers
l'europe envers la politique envers la
démocratie c'est ainsi que nous
combattrons cette défiance et que nous
reconstruirons une europe et une france
dans laquelle nous puissions avoir la
certitude de rayonner encore longtemps
dans le monde et dans l'histoire
au fond nous le savons bien ce qui est
en jeu c'est la crise d'une civilisation
qui se cherche et qui ne sait plus tout
à fait ceux d'hier nous avons élu un
président de la république qui nous a
dit pendant sa campagne il n'y a pas de
culture française
et bien si il y à une culture française
il y à une civilisation européenne et ce
n'est qu'en sachant le dire ce n'est
qu'en sachant le dire encore ce n'est
qu'en sachant donner cette culture a
aimé ce n'est qu'en sachant transmettre
de nouveaux cette civilisation
fier de ses racines et qui trouve dans
ses racines la sève dont elle a besoin
pour continuer d'avancer
ce n'est qu'en sachant partager la force
de cette culture et de cette
civilisation que nous lutterons contre
les communautarismes contre l'islamisme
que nous lutterons contre tous qui
défait l'unité de notre pays
l'unité de notre société l'unité de
notre continent
il faut savoir protéger notre
civilisation
il faut savoir re dire qui nous sommes
et c'est un des enjeux fondamentaux de
cette élection qui commence
en juillet 1943 antoine de saint-exupéry
bien connu dans la région cher laurent
en 1943 antoine de saint-exupéry
écrivait une lettre un général inconnu
la lettre au général x dans laquelle il
disait ce qui compte ce ne sont pas les
êtres
mais ce qui lie les êtres entre eux ce
sont des coutumes une certaines
intonations irremplaçable une certaine
lumière spirituelle
la civilisation est un bien invisible
puisqu'elles portent non sur les choses
mais sur les liens qui les attachent
ainsi et non autrement cette
civilisation qui nous attachent ainsi et
non autrement par des coutumes par une
manière de vivre par une certaines
intonations irremplaçable par une
civilité qui nous relie par des langues
par des traditions par une littérature
une philosophie une histoire c'est ce
qui est en jeu dans ce choix européen
nous faisons partie d'une génération qui
pouvait croire que l'avenir consistait à
gérer tranquillement le déclin eh bien
nous refusons cette fatalité
nous ne voulons pas subir notre avenir
parce que nous sommes européens nous
voulons écrire notre histoire et nous
avons besoin de changer l'europe pour
pouvoir écrire notre histoire et nous
avons besoin de faire les choix qui nous
attendent dans cette élection
les choix courageux est indispensable
que nous avons devant nous qui sont
aussi des choix pour l'avenir de notre
pays qui a besoin de se réformer pour
retrouver confiance en lui nous avons
besoin de ces choix
pour pouvoir croire encore en nous pour
croire qu'il y a un avenir et pour
parler à tous les jeunes que je ne me
résigne pas à voir se détourner de notre
famille politique ou à voir se détourner
de l'idée que la politique peut agir
pour pouvoir changer leur destin alors
au fond
mes chers amis je crois que ma
responsabilité est immense mais c'est
surtout notre responsabilité qui est
grande ce qui nous attachent les uns aux
autres cette civilisation qui nous lie
c'est aussi ce que nous vivons dans ce
mouvement où depuis le début de la
journée je croise chacun d'entre vous
qui vient de partout en france vous avez
fait le trajet vous vous êtes levés très
tôt
vous êtes coucher très tard vous êtes
ici aujourd'hui pour dire que malgré
tout ce qu'on a pu dire et tout ce qu'on
a pu écrire malgré toutes les
spéculations et tous les sondages malgré
toutes les difficultés et les épreuves
subies
vous voulez encore y croire et nous
voulons y croire
ensemble
et bien si vous y croyez encore si vous
y croyez encore c'est le moment de
s'engager
c'est le moment de convaincre c'est le
moment de parler autour de vous dans cet
emploi il j'ai un engagement que je
prends avec toute notre liste toute
notre liste que ce soit les plus jeunes
que ce soient les plus capés nos anciens
ministres comme ceux qui commencent dans
le sillon politique nous avons un
engagement que nous prenons
solennellement devant vous nous allons
tout donner pour vous faire gagner tout
donné mais
je
mais nous avons mais nous avons besoin
de vous nous allons tout donner nous
serons autant que nous pourrons partout
sur le terrain je vois tant de nos
parlementaires que je remercie de leur
confiance qu'ils me disent venez chez
nous venez chez moi venons faire une
réunion
eh bien nous allons faire tout ce que
nous pourrons pour être partout sur le
terrain laurent je te le promets je te
les promis je tiendrais cet engagement
mais nous avons besoin de vous parce que
70 jours c'est court c'est court pour
changer l'histoire et ça ne se fera pas
sans vous je voudrais être votre porte
voix mais il faut que vous soyez nos
voix partout sur le terrain que tous les
jours vous parliez que tous les jours
vous convainquez que tous les jours vous
alliez au contact de ceux qui doutent de
ceux qui ne croit plus en nous pour leur
dire que derrière laurent nous sommes en
train d'écrire une nouvelle page de
l'histoire de la droite qui sera j'en
suis sûr
une nouvelle page de l'histoire de
l'europe au service d'une nouvelle page
d'une nouvelle belle page heureuse dans
l'histoire de la france merci infiniment
je relève
décent pour tous
fermée